and finally new rule call me crazy but
before I put your meat in my mouth I'd
like to know where it's been now the
fourth of July is coming up and I don't
eat meat often but who can resist a
little pink slime when you're toasting
the red white and blue so it's really
bad timing that the republican-led house
just voted this week to get this and get
this and the requirement that meat
labels have to tell us to consumers
where the [ __ ] is from how do you write
that law in a way that explains it's
good for people
what do you name it the freedom from
information act don't worry your pretty
little head about it Act I think I found
the perfect slogan for the Republican
Party combining their two great goals
erasing meat labels and repealing the
estate tax and that slogan is eat [ __ ]
and die
now since 2005 we've had a law that says
when a supermarket sells beef the label
has to say where it came from look
here's a here's look here's a package of
Underpants there's a label on it tells
you where it's from Honduras
they are the underwear makers parks or
here's a pound of ground beef or
whatever where did it come from [ __ ] you
was where camp
if the beef Lobby had its way there'd be
nothing on the label but a picture of a
cow with huge tits killing itself
now since the anti labeling bill hasn't
quite become law yet this one still
tells you where it comes from it says
product of Australia USA Nicaragua and
New Zealand come on no cow is that well
trouble but a single hamburger today and
can contain meat from a hundred cows so
it's more than just delicious it's a
beef based gangbang in your mouth
come on shouldn't you be able to know
that next time you hear Republicans say
they want to protect you from burdensome
regulations this is what they mean but
this isn't really deregulation this is
reverse regulation regulations are
supposed to protect people from
corporations not corporations from
people mm-hmm remember this [ __ ]
Senator Jim Inhofe the guy who brought a
snowball into Congress to prove global
warming is a hoax well he's pretty tired
of NASA studying climate and using data
to bad-mouth carbon so he's threatening
to hold hearings on NASA bias and says
people are going to hear the other side
of the story
yes we need to balance the facts with
the anti facts because we're the United
States if you don't want to know here in
California we had a GMO labeling not
banning just labeling proposition once
and people gave it a resounding hell no
we don't want to know 64 countries label
GMOs Saudi Arabia does it they cover
women from Ed to Tobin
everybody wants to know what's in their
food not here seven states have laws
making it a crime to film inside a
slaughterhouse because when someone did
that and people saw cows too sick to
stand being pushed into the food supply
with a forklift it resulted in the
largest meat recall in history so
naturally the answer that problem was
ban the filming it's weird in America
everyone everyone is under constant
surveillance
except livestock
they apparently need total privacy never
see a chicken on TMZ remember a few
years ago when this chart made the
rounds on the internet showing how big
the chickens we eat have gotten and some
people wanted to know why well it's the
same reason the baseball players got big
for a while admit maybe you should stop
being so nosey and just relax because
when consumers know things they tend to
make informed choices and that could
affect corporate profits oh I'm sorry
but your right to know something is
always going to be outweighed by their
right to hide it from you because in
America you can be armed just not with
the facts